hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
chapter 13 of the categories aristotle
now analyzes another relational term
that we use he just finished talking
about what is prior and by implication
what is posterior now he's going to talk
about what what isn't that what is
simultaneous is how we're translating it
the greek term is hammam and it is
roughly the same sense and as we're
going to see Aristotle thinks that it
has several different related meanings
there's a primary sense and then there's
a number of sort of qualified senses to
the term as well so the primary sense he
says is simultaneity in time that is
things that have come into being
together so you know if you have a twin
and you're not being you know very
careful about you know who is out first
or anything like that you can say that
you're simultaneous in time or if I'm
you know talking in a lecture and thirty
students are listening to it or you know
sitting and watching and suddenly all of
them hear the same argument and it pops
into their head that could all be
simultaneous in time as well but there
could be many other things that are
simultaneous in time these are just
things that have come into being
together and Aristotle says that this is
in fact the most proper and correct
meaning of the term I says neither in
that case is prior nor either posterior
to the other this is just simultaneity
in time much more interesting however
are the cases where we can talk about
things being simultaneous as he says in
nature and this is a derivative sense
right this is foo sada Hamada Tama a
simultaneous in nature he says we apply
this to those things where the being of
either necessitates
that of the other but neither is the
cause of the other so what does this
mean how is it that the being of one is
in some way connected with the being of
the other but neither is actually
causing the other so think about the
examples that it uses double and half as
soon as you cut something into half I
don't have a piece of chalk that I can
break in half unfortunately but assume
that I did right snap one piece becomes
two the original piece was or let's say
we have another piece that's about the
same length as the original piece that
is double we take one of the little
pieces half right they are all coming
into being at the same time but their
being is not dependent upon the other he
says these have a reciprocal dependence
if a double exists than a half if a half
exists also a double even if you're just
imagining something let's say your bank
account something unfortunate happens to
you and you have half as much money in
it as you did last week because somebody
went in and took it or taxes are due or
whoever right if it's half but it's half
in relation to something else it's not
simultaneous in time at all right
because we could go you had double that
money right and now you have half but
those are dependent upon each other this
is the way it works with correlative
terms you're not a father until you have
some children right I suppose you could
say the child can't be a child unless it
unless it had some parents at some time
but that's not really an issue although
in that case of course the the father or
mother is indeed a cause for the child
so perhaps that's not the most apt
example now it gets really interesting
Aristotle says you know another kind of
simultaneity in nature he has to do with
species
that belong to a particular it's a
single genus and he says species marked
off and opposed under one genus each to
the others are called simultaneous in
nature that not prior not posterior
right I mean those marked off or divided
by identical modes of division so he
says here's an example the winget
species is called simultaneous in nature
with both the aquatic and the
terrestrial now when you hear that you
might say wait a second we don't have
winged species you know or aquatic we
have all sorts of aquatic species so
what he's really talking about here is
not species in the proper sense he's
talking about species in terms of a
genus that's part of a larger genus so
largest genus animal right and then one
of the traditional modes of dividing
animals that we don't really use so much
anymore
because we we found other ways to
classify them is to talk about wingin
versus aquatic versus land I mean you
see this not only in Greek philosophy
but you also see this for example in in
religious literature like in the book of
Genesis you know the birds of the sky
the fish of the sea and the cattle of
the land and then there's another
category creeping things or crawling
things right these are ways of dividing
things and let's just assume for the
moment that this works each of those
species ie genera is simultaneous in
relation to the other they imply each
other in a certain way but their being
is not dependent upon each other he says
into these species animal is marked off
by division none will be Prior or
posterior all are in nature simultaneous
each of these species is further marked
off in certain subspecies right each of
which is also simultaneous
so let's say we take water creatures and
let's just assume we're only talking
about fish right so we've got you know
this kind of this family of fish and
this family of fish and this family of
fish I'll use fresh water fish that I'm
a bit more familiar with because I don't
know that much about you know
ocean-going fish so we have you know the
basses and we have the trout's and we
have the Salmons
and we have the pike family right and so
within each of these we can say we've
got fish fish is part of animal right
and fish is divided into these different
you know species as well or genera and
each of those is simultaneous in nature
with each other then we can break them
down further let's take a simple one the
pike family right it's not a hell of a
lot of different kinds of pike so we
have northern pike and we have
muskellunge and then we have the north
northern pike of course exists in Europe
but we also have I think it's called the
armored Pike over in Siberia and then we
have one other kind the pickerel and you
might say wait a second what about the
tiger muskie if you're a fisherman well
that's a blend between northern pike and
muskellunge right so take that one out
of the picture northern pike and
muskellunge are both simultaneous to
each other within the genus of Pike
which is then part of the genus of fish
so you see how all of this works
they are simultaneous not in time bought
in as Aristotle calls it nature because
the being of the things are connected
with each other but neither is the cause
of the other muskellunge is not the
cause of northern pike
however Aristotle goes on and says
something else the genus is prior to the
species so Pike is prior to pickerel our
pike northern pike and muskellunge right
fish is prior to Pike bass trout salmon
whatever I'll throw in their catfish you
know we don't have to go on and on you
get the points right there is still
priority there but the priority has to
do with going up the ladder of being
into higher levels of organization and
abstraction so Aristotle sums up and he
says these are the senses of
simultaneous